est heureux chaque matin qu'il arrive à
la station il monte les escaliers avec
aisance il marche avec à plomb c'est une
amélioration remarquable en quelques
mois Harry peut continuer de travailler
il ne voulait pas arrêter même après 35
ans carrière à CBC
il a couvert les grands événements de
l'actualité
depuis 13 ans il anime le Téléjournal de
18h pour CBC au Nouveau-Brunswick mais
en septembre dernier every forest hell
annonce à ses téléspectateurs qu'il doit
prendre une pause animée devient plus
compliqué
il se rend à l'hôpital western de
Toronto pour subir une délicate
chirurgie à la tête la stimulation
cérébrale profonde d'abord en lui perce
deux trous dans le crâne puis on insère
deux électrodes directement dans le
cerveau sous sa peau on implante
moniteur et deux fils connectés aux
électrodes le moniteur envoie des
signaux électriques qui permettent de
réduire les symptômes du Parkinson
pendant une bonne partie de
l'intervention Hery est éveillé pour
être précis dans l'opération on a
vraiment besoin de cette collaboration
et pour ça le patient doit être éveillé
médical discutent avec lui pour savoir
si articule toujours bien les électrodes
passent tout près de la partie du
cerveau responsable de la parole
impressionné par cette chirurgie Henry
le journaliste veut expliquer au public
ce qui lui arrive et comment sa vie a
changé il diffuse une vidéo en ligne cet
hiver
avec les appareils qu'il a dans les
mains il éteint le moniteur qu'on lui a
installé sous la peau
la réaction est presque immédiate Hery
recommence à trembler
boire un verre d'eau redevient un défi
il réactive son moniteur et rapidement
les tremblements sains
qu'il prend l'opportunité de liker les
gens je ne pense pas que la stimulation
cérébrale profonde c'est quelque chose
que tout le monde connaît
-il a repris le travail en février il
était un bon candidat pour la chirurgie
tous les patients ne sont pas ça dépend
de la réaction médicament de l'évolution
de la maladie notamment
la chirurgie ne va pas guérir la
stimulation cérébrale profonde aide
surtout à calmer les symptômes
que des vignes tranquilles